schuldspruch für taten die fassungslos
machen wegen schweren sexuellen
kindesmissbrauchs werden in münster vier
männer zu langen haftstrafen und
anschließender sicherungsverwahrung
verurteilt delta variante auf dem
vormarsch
studien weisen auf einen geringeren
impfschutz hin und doch werden
reisebeschränkungen gelockert und auf
dem rasen läuft es wieder angelique
kerber spielt sich ins halbfinale von
wimbledon
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem dienstag
die vom sport hat norbert nehmen einen
schirm genannt doch von mir
das übersteige alles was dieser kammer
bisher vorgelegt wurde sagte der
vorsitzende richter in münster heute und
die täter seien eine gefahr für die
allgemeinheit immer und immer wieder
hatten sie kinder schwer sexuell
missbraucht und dabei gefilmt haupt
tatort war diese gartenlaube in münster
aber der fall hatte auch kreise in
andere bundesländer gezogen
sieben männer wurden bereits zu
mehrjährigen haftstrafen verurteilt
im prozess heute stand nun vier männer
vor gericht unter ihnen der
hauptangeklagte und seine mutter ina
baltes berichtet hinter den mauern
dieser gartenlaube müssen sich so sagt
der richter grauenhafte szenen
abgespielt haben
vor laufender kamera vergewaltigen vier
männer zwei kleine jungen tage lang die
taten waren extrem verstörend sagt das
gericht die täter zeigten keinerlei
mitleid erfahrene berufsrichter die
wiederholt und immer wieder mit solchen
fällen beschäftigt sind wurden die
grenzen des vorstellbaren bei weitem
überschritten
insgesamt 29 fälle von kindesmissbrauch
sind dem drahtzieher adrian v
nachgewiesen
dafür bekommt er fasst die
höchstmögliche strafe 14 jahre haft plus
anschließende sicherungsverwahrung das
gericht in münster verhängt auch für die
drei meter hohe strafen und
sicherungsverwahrung
sicherungsverwahrung schließlich an die
hier verhängte strafe an
und das gericht erachtete alle vier
männer hier als gefährlich für die
allgemeinheit
er sucht ein hang festgestellt schwerste
straftaten zu begehen
und dafür soll die allgemeinheit
geschützt werden fünf jahre haft wegen
beihilfe für die mutter von adrian v die
von den taten ihres sohnes gewusst haben
soll
die ermittler kommen den tätern im
darknet auf die spur
adrian v finden sie speicher mit
gigantischen datenmengen 90 beamte und
beamtinnen der ermittlungskommission
rose durchforsten die dateien
ihre arbeit ist noch lange nicht
erledigt wir haben jetzt ein jahr der
ermittlungskommission hinter uns wir
haben ungefähr die hälfte der asservate
ausgewertet und ungefähr die hälfte der
er warte liegt noch vor uns das heißt
ungefähr auch noch ein jahr wenn nicht
wieder neue also erwarte mit dazu kommen
schon jetzt ist die dimension des
netzwerkes erschreckend rund 30
tatverdächtige sitzen bundesweit noch in
untersuchungshaft 32 kinder wurden als
opfer ausgemacht nicht alle sind
identifiziert der tatkomplex münster ist
mit dem urteil heute noch lange nicht
abgeschlossen
die missbrauchsserie in münster ist
neben lüfte und bergisch gladbach einer
von drei großen fällen in wenigen jahren
und offenbar doch nur die spitze eines
eisbergs in unserer zeit erfreute app
finden sie hintergründe zu den taten und
dem täterkreis schauen wir auf die
korona lage das robert koch institut
meldet 440 neue infektionen innerhalb
eines tages 36 mehr als vor einer woche
31 todesfälle kamen binnen eines tages
dazu die bundesweite sieben tage
incidents liegt bei 4,9 aufhorchen
lassen meldungen zur besonders
ansteckenden delta variante nach ansicht
von forschern aus israel schützt der
impfstoff von biontech weise weniger gut
vor einer infektion mit dieser delta
variante als vor früheren corona
varianten vor schweren verläufen schützt
da allerdings schon
jürgen kehl hat die details israel
vorzeigeland im kampf gegen die pandemie
60 prozent der bevölkerung vollständig
geimpft fast alle mit baiser aktuell nur
wenige hundert corona infektionsfälle
doch die zahlen steigen wieder die delta
variante ist da sie erreicht auch
geimpfte die zahlen lag der schutz vor
einer infektion im februar noch bei 95,8
prozent sind es nach aktuellen daten mit
delta jetzt 64 prozent die ist schon
ansteckend da das heißt sie wird schon
leichter weitergegeben und damit eben
auch von einem kämpften eventuell noch
weiter gegeben aber der eigenschutz und
dass er das wichtige bei der impfung der
ist noch da trotz delta impfen mit bei
unterstützt die allermeisten weiter von
einem schweren verlauf gegen die
gemessene wirksamkeit nur leicht von 99
prozent auf jetzt 93 prozent zurück
und brauchen noch mehr daten und delta
noch besser zu verstehen aber zu 93 94
95 prozent verhindert eine impfung eine
schwere probe seiner erkrankung oder den
tod
neu ist die erkenntnis auch bei einer
aktuellen studie aus schottland die
delta variante kann auch geimpfte
infizieren
die zahlen aus israel und aus schottland
zeigen dass man auch als doppelt
geimpfter noch wir es auf den
schleimhäuten tragen kann
ob dieses virus tatsächlich noch so
ansteckend es wie es von jemandem der
nicht geimpftes ist ist nicht klar
denn der gfk hat ihr antikörper und die
setzten sich sofort auf dieses virus
daraufhin reduzieren natürlich auch
dessen ansteckungsfähigkeit geimpft aber
doch möglicherweise ein viren träger die
korona anlage wird durch delta nicht
übersichtlicher obwohl die delta
variante weiter um sich greift hat die
bundesregierung die
einreisebeschränkungen weiter gelockert
fünf länder gelten nicht länger als
virusvarianten gebiete großbritannien
portugal russland indien und nepal das
heißt alle von dort können wieder
einreisen die quarantäne wird verkürzt
oder sie entfällt ganz
theo koll in berlin ist es ein
zugeständnis an alle reisenden oder
warum lockert die bundesregierung diese
beschränkungen
ich glaube es ist eher ein zugeständnis
im blick auf die verfassung
denn da hierzulande ja die
ansteckungskette extrem niedrig ist und
gleichzeitig die zu verhindernde
virusvariante schon dominant ist stellt
sich die frage der verhältnismäßigkeit
von so drastischen eingriffen wie einer
langen quarantäne das gilt dann auch für
die heutige entscheidung wieder bis zu
25.000 zuschauer in den
bundesligastadien zuzulassen
insgesamt ist die politik glaube ich
auch mit blick auf die studien aus
israel in einem prozess das
ansteckungsrisiko und die daraus
folgende gefährlichkeit neu abzuwägen
das heißt zugespitzt gesagt sich nicht
anzustecken ist bei der delta variante
vielleicht gar nicht mehr der alles
überragende faktor gleichzeitig wollen
sich die gesundheitsminister heute abend
damit befassen wie die impfquote noch zu
steigern sein könnte es gibt vorschläge
wie impfen am kiosk oder im
fußballstadion
dann wären immerhin die vielen tausend
zuschauer bei den spielen nicht nur
risiko sondern auch chance dankeschön
nach berlin theo koll wie weiter mit der
korona politik auch schüler und lehrer
wüssten was gern da geht es um
präsenzunterricht und digitales lernen
aber auch um ganz praktische dinge ob
man im nächsten herbst und winter wieder
die fenster aufreißen muss auch wenn das
klassenzimmer zur kühlkammer wird oder
ob doch effektive luftfilter eingebaut
werden
die großen ferien wären eine gute
gelegenheit dazu
was sich da tut sagt britta spiekermann
eine berufsbildende schule in hannover
hier fährt man zweigleisig natürliches
lüften durch offene fenster und seit
neuestem luftfilter mobile geräte die
der schulträger für die klassen
eingekauft hat je nach qualität kosten
sie 304.000 euro
schauen wir mal was nach den ferien
delta mit uns macht aber ich glaube wir
sind an der stelle gut gerüstet und sind
froh und glücklich dass unser
schulträger und diese möglichkeit
gegeben hat das hätte ruhig noch
schneller kommen können und das muss
noch flächendeckender passieren
diese schule ist immer noch eine
ausnahme der deutsche lehrerverband
schätzt dass bis zum ende der
sommerferien bundesweit nur zehn prozent
der schulen mit stationären oder mobilen
raum filtern ausgestattet sein werden
wenn uns wirklich kinder und jugendliche
so viel wert sind wie immer behauptet
wird dann muss man hier auch in solchen
zeiten investitionen tätigen in der
hälfte der länder gibt es
förderprogramme auch der bund stellt 500
millionen euro zur verfügung allerdings
erst seit juni und nur für fest
eingebaute lüftungsanlagen viele
kommunen fürchten hohe kosten für
planung einbau und wartung und stehen
auf der bremse
a&o bleibt lüften garde fenster und die
wissenschaftler sich nicht völlig
täuschen dann ist das wichtigste jene
lüften und frische luft im klassenzimmer
führenden forschern reicht das nicht
wenn man einen entsprechenden luftfluss
hat in den luftfiltern dann
reduzieren sie dass er so zum beispiel
in einem klassenraum sehr gut man kann
in einer halben stunde 90 der eurozone
loswerden viel zeit verstreicht jetzt
ungenutzt in vielen schulen droht ein
déjà vu stoßlüften bei minustemperaturen
ohne luftfilter nach belarus er könne
kein verbrechen eingestehen dass er
nicht verübt habe das sagt der
oppositionspolitiker viktor barbarie co
doch der oberste gerichtshof in minsk
verurteilte heute den früheren bank geht
zur 14 jahren lagerhaft arico galt vor
der präsidentenwahl als
aussichtsreichster gegner von langzeit
machthaber alexander lukaschenko dessen
umstrittene sieg hatte vergangenen
sommer monatelang massenproteste
ausgelöst
axel stein berichtet wenige menschen
sind zum gerichtsgebäude in linz
gekommen anwesend sein mehr ist zurzeit
an unterstützung nicht möglich
victor barcot sitzt wie sieben weitere
angeklagte im stahlkäfig der
ex-bankmanager der präsident werden
wollte den dass lukaschenko regime heute
zu 14 jahren lagerhaft verurteilt
unser mandant kann seit heute keine
berufung mehr einlegen
wir werden das urteil trotzdem auf
anderem wege anfechten wir werden auch
vor dem un menschenrechtsausschuss die
verletzung der rechte unseres mandanten
zur sprache bringen
geldwäsche bestechung
steuerhinterziehung werfen sie baba rico
vor er streitet das ab
im vergangenen jahr will er präsident
werden will belarus gen westen führen
und wird langzeit diktator lukaschenko
gefährlich als seine männer barrios
wahlbüro stürmen sitzt er schon in haft
das urteil für baba ricco war absolut
vorhersehbar
es passt zur logik der behörden alle
gegner die zivilgesellschaft zu
unterdrücken das sehen wir seit einem
jahr
die kritik am urteil auch die aus
deutschland ist deutlich schauprozess
inszenierung willkür so die kommentar
die umstrittene wahl mit lukaschenko als
sieger fand oliver rico statt aber nach
seiner festnahme arbeitete die
opposition zusammen sie tut es bis heute
unter schwierigen bedingungen der
machthaber in minsk geht gegen kritiker
mit aller härte vor
wie kann landwirtschaft in deutschland
umweltfreundlich und gesund sein und
sich lohnen darüber heimlich unter
anderem bauern und vertreter aus natur-
und verbraucherschutz gedanken gemacht
heute übergab die zukunftskommission
landwirtschaft ihren bericht an die
bundeskanzlerin
darin der appell finanzielle förderung
künftig an umwelt- und klimapolitische
kriterien zu knüpfen
zudem müsse sich die ernährung der
deutschen ändern weniger fleisch ist das
stichwort
weil all das mehr kostet soll der staat
landwirte und verbraucher mit niedrigem
einkommen unterstützen wollen
170 hektar bestes acker und weideland
stadt die zahl der tiere zu steigern hat
sich junge bäuerin elisabeth fräsen aus
niedersachsen bewusst dafür entschieden
nur 100 kühe und ihren nachwuchs zu
halten die herde klein ihre bio fleisch
produkte teurer fräsen hat sich eine
nische gesucht und gehört zu einer
generation die die landwirtschaft
nachhaltig verändern will wir bäuerinnen
und bauern müssen etwas tun für
klimaschutz und tierwohl zum beispiel
aber auch verbraucher innen müssen ihr
verhalten ändern und zum beispiel
weniger fleisch essen mehr geld für
lebensmittel ausgeben und auch die
politik ist gefordert vor einem jahr
bekam fräsen den auftrag von der
bundesregierung zusammen mit vertretern
aus 30 organisationen eine vision für
eine nachhaltige landwirtschaft mit zu
entwickeln
herausgekommen ist eine gemeinsame
empfehlung für eine zukunftstaugliche
agrarpolitik im kern mehr umweltschutz
weniger fleischkonsum und weniger tiere
in ställen ernährungssicherung ist nicht
denkbar ohne leistungsfähige
landwirtschaft und es müssen
verlässliche finanzielle
rahmenbedingungen geschaffen werden
sonst wird sich niemand auf diesen
transformationsprozess einlassen die
deutsche umwelthilfe sieht die chance
zum ausstieg aus der massentierhaltung
als verpasst das sind aber alles
absichtserklärung keine festen fristen
und damit gelingt natürlich der
systemwechsel vor allem bei der
industriellen massentierhaltung nicht
die erwünschte wende in der
landwirtschaft liefert was kosten da ist
sich landwirt holger handys sicher die
gesellschaft sagt die messe bio
landwirtschaft
dann muss ich auch bereits einsatz zu
bezahlen und sie muss dann auch in kauf
nehmen dass auf den flächen deutlich
weniger produziert wird die vielen
bauern proteste waren der anlass die
zukunftskommission einzusetzen für die
konkrete umsetzung der vorschläge ist
die nächste regierung zuständig ein
echtes filmfestival mit echtem publikum
wie sich das nochmal anfühlt daran will
kann ab heute abend erinnern
und zwar so glamourös wie möglich von
jodie foster über sean penn bis marion
cotillard sind eine ganze reihe stars an
die côte d'azur gereist und die jury
leitet diesmal us regisseur spike lee
zwei dutzend filme bewerben sich um die
goldene palme und gleich geht's mit
einem musical drama los thomas walde
dieser rote soll zum symbol eines
neubeginns werden weit über kann
als ich per e-mail hierher eingeladen
wurde fragte ich mich ob das festival
wohl stattfindet angesichts der gefahr
durch die pandemie dass wir alle heute
hier sind grenzt an ein wunder
oma wir realisieren wohl erst jetzt was
wir ein besonderer moment das ist mit
diesem sehr speziellen festival bei
einer historischen stadt um das virus
soll es nun um den wettbewerb gehen 24
filme ringen um die goldene palme schon
mit der nominierung von der jury will
kann maßstäbe setzen die mitglieder sind
mehrheitlich frauen der vorsitzende zum
ersten mal bei einem großen festival ein
schwarzer künstler dann ist das
bedeutendste festival der welt das soll
andere nicht herabsetzen in ihrer oma
jodie foster r dem driver in kernen
finden das kino und die stars nach einer
zwangspause wieder zu ändern
heute abend sind sich zum ersten mal
seit 15 monaten in einem kino
[Musik]
der erste film im wettbewerb am ersten
abend ist annett mit marion cotillard
unter dem driver in den hauptrollen es
ist eine musik komödie so leicht
markiert kann die rückkehr des großen
kinos
der vom orden zum grünen teppich norbert
in knapp zwei stunden ist es so weit das
erste em halbfinale italien gegen
spanien das aufeinandertreffen zweier
fußball giganten vor gigantischer
zuschauer kulisse im londoner wembley
stadion das duell der beiden
halbfinalisten fast auf augenhöhe
das wembley stadion ist präpariert
60.000 zuschauer werden erwartet
leicht favorisiert sind die italiener
auch dank ihrer starken abwehr axel ini
und bonucci ddp
wir wollen natürlich großartiges leisten
werden uns leidenschaftlich präsentieren
wir haben respekt vor dieser aufgabe
aber wir wollen gewinnen ab oder kassel
statt
machbar wenn auch in sinn hier offensiv
ähnlich auftrumpft wie zuletzt aber
einfach wird es nicht gegen spanien
andreas stammen vor dem wembley-stadion
60.000 zuschauer trotz steigender corona
zahlen wir sehen dass die londoner
also hier in wembley interessiert dass
momentan niemanden das sind tausende
italienische und spanische fans und die
wollen ein fußball-fest sehen und feiern
natürlich alles fans mit wohnsitz in
großbritannien
denn die anreise aus dem ausland war
wegen chor ohne restriktionen nicht
möglich da gehen in dieser euphorie dann
auch die meldungen unter das etwa beim
vorrundenspiel schottland england von
den 2500 schottischen fans ins stadion
sich 400 mit corona infiziert haben und
da muss man sagen das ist eine zahl die
die schon angst macht und die britische
regierung hat auch bislang und auch die
uefa nicht wirklich klar gemacht ob das
nicht ein zu hoher preis ist für solche
fußballfeste die man feiern will
und jetzt gehen dreimal so viele leute
ins stadion die täglichen
infektionszahlen haben sich nochmal
verdreifacht auf fast 29.000 fälle
täglich seit diesem schottland
vorrundenspiel
also das ist schon los die mit sehr viel
vorsicht zu genießen ist
danke andreas stamm zur tour de france
nach dem extrem harten alpen wochenende
heute eine flachetappe für die sprinter
und die gewann der brite mark cavendish
vor den bürgern wort von art & jasper
philippsen schon sein dritter
etappensieg bei dieser tour
bester deutscher war andré greipel als
angelique kerber hat ihre siegesserie
beim tennisturnier in wimbledon
fortgesetzt deutschlands beste keine
spielerin gewann gegen die tschechin
karolina woche war souverän in zwei
sätzen und steht jetzt im halbfinale
strahlendes lächeln nach ganz reife
leistung je länger die partie dauerte
desto mehr zermürbt der angelique kerber
carolina moko war vor allem dank ihrer
starken rückhand imponierte die
33-jährige mit direkten gewinnschlägen
aber auch läuferisch und über kopf eine
nahezu perfekte vorstellung der
deutschen extrem frustrierend für ihre
24 jährige tschechische gegnerin körper
zum vierten mal im wimbledon halbfinale
6 zu 2 und 6 zu 3
laut donnerstag spielt sie dann gegen
die weltranglisten-erste fc barcelona
australien die daumen eine sandburg kann
man mit schäufelchen und einbauen oder
wie es jetzt in dänemark machen und den
sand mit viel technik auf über 21 meter
auftürmen
neuer weltrekord für die details der
burg arbeiteten sich dann 30 künstler
schrittweise von oben nach unten
warum es hält im sand steckt eine kleine
prise leben einfach wunderhübsch
anzusehen nur mit einem klitzekleinen
marke behaftet die burg steht nicht um
strand die nacht bringt heftige gewitter
die details zum wetter hat gleich ist
intern marietta slomka begrüßt sie im
heute journal um viertel nach elf
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
unbeschwerten abend und bis morgen wenn
sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein für gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die hitze bei uns wird allmählich
nach osten hin abgedrängt ein hoch über
russland blockiert den weg der tiefs und
so wird diese hitze weit in den norden
transportiert wie die tage zuvor bis
nach skandinavien
bei uns kommt etwas kühlere luft an und
so liegen die temperaturen meist um die
25 grad marke in der nacht in den
nächsten stunden gibt heftige gewitter
im süden und im osten mit platzregen und
hagel im westen lockert es auf
temperaturen in der eifel bis 9 grad und
sonst im osten um die 18 grad
und morgen am vormittag gibt es im osten
noch regen und auch im sinne aber dann
zum nachmittag lockert es auf einzelne
schauer dann im osten und auch an den
alpen gewitter entwickeln sich dann im
tagesverlauf an der nordsee
die höchsten temperaturen dann bei 26
grad in den östlichen landesteilen sowie
in bayern 20 grad an den alpen ja und
die nächsten tage
am donnerstag gibt es heftige unwetter
von südwesten her bis 26 grad warm und
am freitag dann die gewitter weiter im
südosten und im osten des landes und
auch weiterhin unwetterartig und damit
ein schöner abend